all right let me start off this video by
apologizing for my perhaps somewhat
terrible voice today oh I I decided to
catch a call once again you know it's
been two weeks since I got the last one
so and why not get another one but
that's not the main thing I want to talk
about one of the other really kind of
important things at the moment is next
next week is going to be vacation for
all of us and we're all happy but I'm
actually going to go to Austria and that
means that I can't really do too much
roller coaster in three related I'll
bring my laptop over there and that's
also something that I'm going talk to go
to talk about in a bit but the thing is
I can't produce videos obviously but I
also haven't been able to produce more
videos to release in that week because
of homework and other related things so
really what it comes down to now is I've
got a week of me not being able to
produce or release anything and I've
only got two videos too at the moment as
a kind of buffer so that's not really an
ideal situation but I am probably going
to do some roller coaster tycoon three
related things and oh my god i just
noticed how different my voices today
because of that cold but I am yeah I am
going to do some ICT three related
things but most of those things will
actually be working on custom Siri
thingies and now you might be like hell
what you do that stuff yeah I used to a
couple of years ago almost that's that
at least that's how long ago it seems
but you might know the situation right
now where I have worked on well over 10
custom scenery sets and never finished
any of them and this also brings me in a
kind of situation where I like to hate
on people never release their custom
scenery set yet in the meantime I'm
probably the absolute ruler of not
created of not releasing though custom
scenery so I decided to just remove all
of those things and try to put all of
the most popular pieces into one set
call it something like silver to random
stuff for something like that and
release it and now this will include
some of the arches that you may or may
not have seen already some classical
arches and some steampunk ones I'll
possibly release the pipes on it too and
so fur coat my connectors because as you
all know I love for coma because Dutch
pride and other things among which was
actually something which i'm still
flabbergasted about is the fact that
that was a very canadian about i have no
idea where that came from but the fact
that nobody ever made a custom scenery
set for B&M connectors as in track
connectives and my track connectors I
don't mean the infamous Trek connectors
like cosa nostra connectors because I'm
not too much of coaster nerd but it
turns out apparently that those things
aren't actually try connectors but
they're called support connectors or
something like that hmm but the thing is
on vm trikes on while basically every
track the track is made out of different
elements that you connect with flanges
and mobi steel jungles flanges but the
be an Amtrak doesn't have any of those
things unlike the No Limits wreck for
example so I had the idea at some point
in time to make flanges to connect the
track part with and just make the track
look more realistic overall so that's
what's going to happen with that and
other things um I mean I keep on
coughing and it need to edit that out
all the time this is not really the
ideal situation right here I perhaps I
should actually talk about what I'm
doing in rolla co 2nd three right now
well this was the episode or at least
the live stream at which I was doing all
of this where I decided to you know what
I need to add details but that was not
my entire train of thought obviously I
looked on that flat ride over there I
was like I need to finish that area but
I didn't feel like doing that I really
didn't feel like doing that so decided
to procrastinate that and work on random
details in the park and
I'd say that's not a bad idea I'd say
that's probably something that everyone
should try every once in a while to just
revisit your park look at things and
figure well this could be better I could
use a custom scenery set that I haven't
used here before or I could use some
random details over here for example
this little flat right over here I don't
I've no idea what kind of sense this
thing should make I was pretty much
inspired I don't know if you call that
inspired by and well should I really do
this you know I'm just going to go for
it when you have lakes or ponds or
anything that's made out of water in the
Netherlands are basically the entire
[ __ ] country you need these little
things to pump away to water and I
figured hey I've made this lake over
here and that's all nice and dandy and
stuff but there is no exit for the water
so I decided to add that so there it is
there is the place whether what it can
just go away and that's when I opened
spooky themed objects and I saw station
Jim's stuff and a new world opened for
me seriously I never actually looked
into these objects but then I opened one
of those sets I don't even remember
which one it was it was either like um
ghost shot no wait it was goes mining I
remember because I did not see that
coming at all I did not realize that
goes mining would actually be a useful
set and then I noticed that goes mining
was a set with awesome random small
things that you can just add anywhere
and anything that's great so I decided
to do that and built this little
something seriously I have no idea what
the hell that actually is and that this
thing definitely still need some more
work in terms of maybe details still and
maybe in terms of what it actually is
but I'm not entirely sure about this
right but i might add some small other
towers
spooky buildings things like that
because at the moment although I do like
the look of this ride the Themis kind of
still vague and I could say that about
the rest of the pike as well but still
for this ride in particular it's got
that spooky Alpine medieval steampunk
theme going on but I don't don't know if
that actually makes sense and that's
really all the rest of that ride I might
add some more details like i said but
i'm not too sure about that anyway I
just felt like working this thing again
and i just realized my voice is really
going to the [ __ ] right now and I'm
sorry for the language but I don't know
if this is really profession huh this is
incredibly not professional oh well you
know sometimes I feel like I don't know
if that's just me but sometimes and I'm
actually a [ __ ] tits I digress way too
much sometimes I feel like I'd rather
want to watch somebody who has like
three thousand subscribers or something
like that and just makes very amateur
estate videos rather than somebody with
a five-thousand-dollar microphone and a
camera team behind him who makes every
video perfect and never fails to do
anything well never does anything wrong
I mean and I don't know to me it just
feels more real and that might just be
me but that's not an excuse to be there
terribly not professional that's stupid
I didn't even know why i SAT night but
that's just my opinion than that
seriously that is my kind of YouTube
taste I like when people just mess up on
their videos and don't cut it out
because seriously we're all humans and
mistakes are also fun seriously so that
being said though I walk edit out Mike
I've seen this because I holy [ __ ] that
is terrible but oh wait no think about
the great things in life seriously so
flowers plenty of flowers I think I did
actually again get the criticism then I
am placing too many flowers in my Park
which again yes I am placing way too
many flowers in this bike like
realistically speaking they're all still
next to depart and they're not standing
like underneath trees they should have
enough sunlight and water and all that
but it's a ridiculous amount of flowers
to maintain and it's possibly impossible
so might not be the best idea but then
again like I said I'll do anything and
say that is this park is meant to be
over the top and unrealistic and that's
my excuse for everything so I'm sorry
about that and I must say I'm not too
happy about how this right turn out and
I could partly blame that on the fact
knowledge placement over here is just
very annoying on a cliff site like that
and the overall layout just where it is
within the park doesn't make too much
sense and that's my fault though but
yeah I might just not film too much of
that of that ride it is pretty much just
there to fill up the emptiness over
there because otherwise there wouldn't
been anything else over there and
they're just be a lack of flat rise in
the park as a whole and that's not
something that you'd want to have but
anyway that's it for the for today and
this is going to be the last episode in
quite a while and hopefully next time
I'm going to be a little more help a bit
more wow that was terrible a bit more
healthy and actually back from Austria
and ready to do loads of awesome things
again so thanks for watching and see you
then